all of the torque problems I've done so
far on the physics playlist we only just
figured out the magnitude of torque but
well frankly because that's what
normally matters but torque is actually
a vector and it's Direction can be found
and that is because torque is defined as
the cross-product between the radial
distance from your axis of rotation and
the rotational force being applied so
these are both vectors so let's take a
look at how I taught you a vectors the
first time and then I'll show you how
that's really the same thing as what
we're doing here with the cross-product
except now with the cross-product
besides just the magnitude for torque
we're also getting the direction but
then we'll also see that that direction
is a little bit it's just kind of the
definition of the direction of torque
I don't know how intuitive it really is
but what did I teach you before about
torque well I said if I had a let's say
I had some arm say that's the arm and
let's say it's it's you know this could
be the hand of a clock or it's pinned
down to the wall there so it would
rotate around this object and then let's
let me switch colors the magenta is
getting a little obnoxious let's say
it's some distance R from the pivot
let's say that distance is 10 all right
this is the same thing as R and the
magnitude of R is equal to 10 at some
distance 10 from the pivot I apply some
force F and F I will do in yellow I
apply some force F let me do it let me
draw it straight I apply some force F at
some angle that's my force F it's also a
vector has magnitude and direction and
let's say let's say that this is 10
meters and let's say that I apply a
force of I don't know 7 Newtons let me
let me make it more interesting let's
say I apply a force of square root of 3
nu
and I just threw that out there because
I think the numbers will all work out
and let's say that the angle between my
force and the lever arm or the arm
that's rotating let's stick to radians
this time stick to radians let's say
it's PI over 3 but if you need to
visualize that that's 60 degrees PI over
3 radians because a it's equal to theta
and so just just based on what we
already know about moments or torque
what is the what is the torque around
this pivot or how much torque is being
applied by this force and when we learn
torque I'm going to learn moments we
realize really the only hard part about
these problems is that you don't just
multiply the entire rotational force
times the distance from the axis of
rotation you have to multiply the
component of that force that is actually
doing the rotation or the component of
the force that is perpendicular to this
rotating arm or perpendicular to this
moment arm so how do we figure that out
well the component of this of this force
that is perpendicular to this arm I can
visually draw it here see it would be
looks something like this
like that
I could draw it there I could also draw
it here right that would be this would
be the component or this would be the
component that is perpendicular to this
rotating arm and the component that is
parallel would be this but we don't care
about that that's kind of not
contributing to the rotation the only
thing is contributing the rotation is
this component of the force and what is
the magnitude of this vector right here
the component of vector F that is
perpendicular to this arm well if this
angle let me draw a little triangle down
here if this is square root of 3 this is
PI over 3 radians or 60 degrees then
this is and this is a right angle it's
PI over 3 and it's hard to read what is
this length right here what's a 30-60-90
triangle and we know that this length
here I mean there's a couple of ways you
could think about
we know trigonometry we know that this
is just a square root of three times the
sine of PI over three or the sine of 60
degrees and so that equals the square
root of three sine of PI over three or a
sine of 60 degrees is square root of
three over two so square root of three
times the square root of 3 is just 3 so
that equals three halves so the
magnitude of this force vector that is
perpendicular the component that is
perpendicular to the arm is three over
two Newtons and now we can figure out
the magnitude of the torque it's three
over two Newton's times ten meters so we
know the magnitude of the torque and I'm
being a little bit more careful with my
notation right now to remind you the
torque actually is a vector or you can
almost view it as a they use this term
pseudo vector because it's kind of a
well anyway I won't go into that so what
is the magnitude of the torque vector
well it's three-halves newtons times the
distance and I remember I just drew this
vector here just to show you the
component I could just shift the vector
here because this is actually where the
force is being applied you could draw
that same vector here because you can
shift vectors around so this is also
three 1/2 Newtons and maybe that makes a
little bit clearer so it's three-halves
Newtons and times the distance that you
are from your pivot arm so times 10
meters and so that is equal to what 15
Newton meters so the magnitude of the
torque is 15 Newton meters but all we
did now and hopefully this this looks a
little bit familiar this is what we
learned when we learned moments in
torque but all we did now is we figured
out the the magnitude of the torque but
what if we wanted to know the direction
and that's where the cross-product comes
in so what was the definition of the
cross-product cross product R cross F
that is equal to magnitude of R times
the magnitude of F
times sign of the smallest angle between
them times some vector that is
perpendicular to both and this is really
where it's going to help because all of
these right here these are all scalar
quantities right so these will specify
the direction this but the direction is
completely specified by this unit vector
and a unit vector is just a vector of
magnitude one that's pointing in some
direction well look this cross-product
this part of it the part that just gives
us magnitudes we just calculated that
using what we knew before of torques the
magnitude of our force vector times sine
of theta that gave us the component of
the force vector that is perpendicular
to the arm and we just multiply that
times the magnitude of R and we got the
magnitude of the torque vector which was
1515 we could leave out the Newton the
Newton meters for now 15 and then its
direction is this vector that we specify
by n we could call the normal vector and
what do we know about this vector it's
perpendicular to both R this is R right
this is our and it's perpendicular F and
the only way that I can visualize in our
three-dimensional universe a vector
that's perpendicular to both this and
this if it pops in or out of this page
right because both of these vectors are
in the plane that are defined by our
video so the if I'm if I'm a vector
that's perpendicular to your screen
whatever you're watching this on then
it's going to be perpendicular to both
of these vectors and how do we figure
out if that vector pops out or pops into
the page we use the right hand rule
right the right hand rule we take R is
our index finger F is our middle finger
and then whichever direction our thumb
points in tells us whether or not we are
the direction of the the cross product
so let's draw it let me see if I can do
a good job right here so if that is my
index finger that's my index finger and
you can kind of imagine like the your
your hand sitting on top of this screen
right so that's that's my index finger
representing our and this is my right
hand remember it only works with your
right hand if you do your left hand is
going to be the opposite and then my my
middle finger is going to go in the
direction of F and then the rest of my
fingers are and I encourage you to draw
this so if I were to draw it let me draw
my nails just so you know what this is
so this is the nail on my index finger
that's the nail on my middle finger and
so in this situation where as my thumb
I'm going to be my thumb is going to be
popping out I wish I could and that's
the nail of my thumb hopefully that
makes some sense right that's the paw
might sound at the other side of my and
then I could keep drawing but hopefully
that makes some some sense this is my
index finger this the middle finger my
thumb is pointing out of the page so
that tells us that the torque is
actually pointing out of the page so
that the direction of this unit vector n
is going to be out of the page and we
could signify that by a circle with the
dot and I'm almost at my time limit and
so there you have it torque is applied
to or the cross product as it is applied
to torque see in the next video